hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game between these two
gentlemen we've seen in round one of the
ancient rapid Knockouts uh the
quarterfinals Magnus escaped almost a
certain Doom uh where I mean it was just
such a such a wild game 136 moves where
Arjun was pushing for the win but then
after that crucial Point Magnus was able
to get the game to a point where Arjun
had only one winning move and uh he
missed it due to uh time trouble Magnus
was able to to save the game with a draw
now Magnus has the white pieces and
again it's um a very very wonderful game
so let's dive straight into it so Magnus
uh opens with Knight to F3 he goes for
the ready opening Pawn to D5 by Arjun
and now G3 going for the king's Indian
attack on the C5 Bishop to G2 and Knight
to F6 we have castles and the G6 now
preparing to think get to the dark
Square Bishop we have Pawn to D4 and now
C captures on D4 we have Knight captures
on D4 and now Bishop to G7 so this has
been reached quite a few times even in
the scenefield cup uh this year C4 was
played in the game between Maxima
shielogram and Hans Neiman that ended in
a draw but here we have Knights the B3
it is uh also the one of the more
popular replies Knight to C6 and now
Knight the C3 we have Pawn to E6 Ponte
E4 and now you have to decide do you
want to capture an E4 do you want a
castle do you want to push D4 uh this is
what um Arjun plays he pushes D4 we have
E5 by Magnus D captures in C3 and now
there is a game where Bishop captures
and C6 was played it was played in 2019
between maximately with Gujarati that
ended in a draw but here we have e
characters on F6 and it is now as of
move 11 that we have a completely new
game so uh you could capture with the
bishop you could capture with the queen
you could capture with the queen on D1
there are many POS possibilities here
for example if Queen captures an F6
Queen D7 D6 is quite unpleasant not
allowing black to Castle Bishop captures
and C6 being the option so maybe you
don't have time to bring the queen back
into the the the defensive via Queen D7
so it's a very tricky move of course
black can play it but if you don't know
it maybe don't play it so instead Bishop
captures on F6 is what Arjun goes for
and now B captures and C3 which is very
nice as the bishop can now come to A3
here Arjun castles and now Queen to F3
for the moment declining the queen trade
Bishop G7 and now Queen Bishop to A3
going after the rook and f8 Rook the E8
and now Rook 8 to B1 you want to get the
Rook off of this diagonal and the other
Rook will come to D1 so here Queen to F6
Arjun knows that this is coming so he
might as well offer a queen trade and
then he will go after that C3 Pawn but
Magnus just captures captures and goes
Rook F to D1 he doesn't mind the
opponent C3 and obviously as this is
something he plays he obviously prepared
it Yankee will have full development he
is down a pawn but he will have some
very nice compensation so Bishop
captures on C3 and now Knights the C5
and all of a sudden it seems like it's
not all that easy defending this Pawn
here uh so what what can you play one
way to do it is just the play A5 and
this seems like the B this seems to be
the way to go where white um now has a
has a few options of course you could go
after the B7 Pawn but now it would be
better to go for something like 94
attack the bishop put pressure on F6 put
pressure on D6 so probably what what
Magnus had in mind as A5 is the top move
recommended by by the engine so if he
prepare this at home obviously he knows
the ins and outs of the position but
moves like Rook to beat of course are
impossible just Bishop captures now you
can't capture back because the real
Kings of course you do not want to play
B6 this opens up the diagonal so here
Bishop back to F6 by arjune and now we
have Knight captures on B7 just nicely
recollecting the pawn bishop capture Sun
B7 Rook captures on B7 and now Knight to
D4 putting pressure on the C2 pawn and
now Pawn to C4 so it's equal material
but Magnus has the best pair and he does
have the past C Pawn so if he can start
pushing it that will be very good for
him Rook 8 to C8 and now Bishop to F1
for the moment defending the pass Pawn
Rook e to d8 and now King to G2 with
font A5 now not allowing the pawn to be
captured and the pawn to C5 now Magnus
starts advancing the pass Pawn Rook the
B8 offering Rook trade and The Rook the
B6 now are offering the trade button B6
and if you go for this it's not uh all
that great because uh for example Rook
to be it goes after the pawn there's
Bishop C5 attacks the Knight defends the
pawn and you can't go after the bishop
these two squares are unavailable for
tonight and if you go Knight the C6 just
Rook to D7 followed uh following uh Pawn
to B7 and Bishop D6 going after the Rook
this is resigns for black so instead
Arjun has to figure out how to play this
best for Arjun here is to play Knight to
C2 it comes with tempo as the bishop on
A3 is hanging and it's not easy to play
this for example if root capture 78 Rook
captures and now Bishop the C1 uh it's
perfectly fine there's no uh no no
worries here and if you try something
instead of Bishop to C1 like C6 you want
to give up the bishop for maybe some C7
and Rook to B8 action uh there's a
bishop to D4 attacking the rook and once
The Rook moves there's a rook the C8
attacking the pawn and if C7 Bishop E5
now stops Rook to B8 and this is how you
defend but that's uh that's a lot of
precise moves that you have to play in
that order instead Arjun played King to
G7 and this allows the Magnus one move
that allows him to play this game for
the win so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this idea while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh spotting that
you have to guard the queening square
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is the best of the A6
that's the only way to do it and now
this Pawn is marching forward uh now the
thing is if you go Knight to C2 now you
go after the bishop now you you you're
out of time because not just the Rook
captures through captors and pawn to C6
if Knight captures on A3 C7 and now the
bishop guards the queening square if
Rook to f8 you can even play Rook the B8
and uh well that's that's pretty much it
after Bishop to E5 of course
um uh you you you you cannot allow the
pawn to promote a rook capture Center f8
and now you are not in time because of
queening so you have the cap run C7 and
now the Rook just goes back so we will
have uh you will be up the exchange and
you will have a very very nice winning
end game so instead after Bishop A6
Arjun played Pawn to E5 and now just
Rook the B1 by Magnus putting pressure
on The Rook here so Knight to C6
defending the Rook now Rook captures is
impossible because of Rook captures on
B1 but now just Rook 1 to B5 Now The
Rook is nicely defended and this is now
a threat so Arjun has to trade Rook
captures C captures on B6 and now Pawn
to E4 but now Pawn uh Bishop to C5
regarding that E3 Square so no no tricks
are possible Rook to D2 and now we have
Pawn to B7 preparing Pawn to B8 so
Knights the B8 blocking that uh square
and now we have Rook captures on A5 by
Magnus Rook to D7 putting pressure on
the pawn now the idea is we're going to
capture the bishop and after Rook
captures just collect the pawn on B7 but
now Bishop to C4 now Magnus gives up the
B Pawn because now he has the past a
pawn so Rook captures on B7 and now
Bishop to D5 attacking The Rook ended
upon here you cannot defend it so Rook
does the D7 attacking the bishop and
Bishop capture Sun E4 and now at the
outside pass Pawn The Bishop's pair it
will be very hard to defend against this
as the bishop pair can be used very
nicely to escort the pass Pawn down up
the board so Bishop to D4 now offering a
trade of Bishops just Bishop to B4
Magnus prefers to keep them for the
moment Rook the A7 offering a rook trade
and this he goes for Rook captures
Bishop capture Sun A7 and now just Pawn
to A4 we have King to F6 now comes
Bishop to D5 now the king cannot go
further as Bishop captures on F7 will
will come so Knight to A6 attacking the
bishop but now Bishop C5 creating a wall
against the black king but also keeping
an eye on that Knight on A6 so yeah it
can't really move unless you want to
trade it so here Bishop to B6
uh in the uh guarding the the A5 square
but now just Bishop to C4 attacking the
Knight here uh Knight to C7 and now
Bishop to B4 guarding the A5 Square so
now A5 is coming Bishop to D4 and now
Pawn to A5 we have Pawn to H5 uh you
have to play something Pawn to A6 with
Knight the E8 now uh and now Pawn to F4
we have knighted to C7 now guarding the
eighth square but not Bishop to D6 just
going after the Knight Knight the A8 and
now Bishop to D5 attacking the Knight
here Knight to B6 attacking the bishop
on D5 but here Magnus just pushes Pawn
to A7 and he was in this position unmu
48 that Arjun ergasi resigned the game
which means that Magnus takes the lead
in their match and Arjun will now have
to fight the bonds back and uh well try
try and remain in the match so here you
resign because there's nothing for you
to do if you capture here just just the
the pawn gets Queen and if you do
nothing then A8 Queen and you will have
to give up that Knight and the uh the
thing is why it's not even in a rush
like if you move the king Magnus can
even capture on F7 he's not in a rush to
Queen the pawn if the if the bishop
moves from this diagonal then even
Bishop to C5 will force the Knight away
somewhere and then Queen the pawn so
there's really nothing for you to do
here it's absolutely you know complete
to swung
uh so yeah very nicely played by Magnus
especially after surviving that game one
I mean there's definitely a tough Break
um I mean sorry it's not very similar
but here after uh June allowed this
bishop to A6 move which is the only
winning idea for Magnus uh you would
have to play like a series of incredibly
incredible moves um to to try and keep
this game going but he he played a few
sub-optimal moves uh in in a couple of
positions and that was uh more than
enough for Magnus to take the full point
here uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it if you haven't seen the
previous video do check it out it's
absolute Master Class 136 moves of of
just excruciating pain you you guys will
enjoy it I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Jimmy LeBlanc and I
would like to thank Anderson Vera torko
stand with ravishing reptiles YouTube
and Trevor Terrace for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day